length of we'll just pick them randomly
how about this you you pick uh
somebody okay and then i'll i'll you
don't tell me don't tell me we'll just
i'll i'll try to find out the their
strength uh and then
i think that'll be a cool side bet you
know who who
will i'll try to guess their strength
how about how about that
best of luck you have the white pieces
okay sounds good
let's start with g2 to g4
what do you think uh the strength of the
player who's playing with white pieces
[Laughter]
g4 is yeah i think it's only slightly
worse than passing
d7 d5 bishop f1 to g2
so you're hoping he takes on g4 and you
pick up the bishop he
did take on g4 what a brave warrior huh
c2 to c4
d5 takes c4 well bishop g2 takes on b7
looks like your opponent is not
surprised by your choice knight b8 to d7
[Music]
hmm
that's the music of the day um should i
accept that
sacrifice the question
question is how lost are you if you
don't
i'm gonna try some something uh
simple a quin from d1 to a4
you got 412 he has 440.
he or she i don't know as an attacking
player should probably know that
you don't want to accept any sacrifice
you only want to give any
i've never heard of that concept before
and i don't endorse it
fell into deep thought after queen a4 i
guess that might be a novelty huh
i don't know lot to learn from this game
for kids so far
go g4 and move your bishop couple times
then bring your queen out
and don't accept any sacrifices don't
take stuff
i had on the clock already due to the
shock value of this move
bishop g4 to e6
okay interesting
i'm gonna play knight f3
right f6 g8 f6
okay knight b1 to c3
i don't know if i have a lot of viewers
from hamburg but uh
i got rained on pretty hardcore before
coming out here yeah yeah so did i
stability of hamburg even though it
looks like a nice day can
turn on you within seconds
this game feels like uh alternate
universe where
rooks are worse than bishops or
something yeah confused
you don't take it he doesn't remove it
hopefully rook still will move like
rooks huh i guess so yeah
c7 to c6
okay
i'm gonna play knight f3 to d4
you're ahead on the clock 339 versus
240.
this almost feels like a classical game
i wouldn't call it a classic
just yet but it feels
feels slow for sure d7 to e5
okay let's see
okay let's uh it's too tempting knight
d4 takes on e6
followed by f2 to f4 pre-move done
he played f takes e6
knight e5 to d7
okay
[Music]
let me figure out where the stuff is at
i think it's about time to collect some
harvest now
always is
okay let's start out with
let's go quintex c4
got it
we'll see how how long that rook on
eight is going to be hanging
rook a8 to b8 bishop b7 takes on c6
should play one g4 more often watching
this
you know as a part of my blindfold
exhibition matches i play all sorts of
uh moves on the first moves
b8 to c8 okay let's uh pick up another
pawn right there quinn
c4 takes on e6
queen d8 to b6 oh man i don't want to
give up that bishop
let's try bishop c6 takes d7
knight takes d7
and queen e6 over to e4
you got 209 here's 141 knight f6
quinn f3
e7 e6
haha let's try
b2 to b3
bishop b4 bishop to b2
short castles
e2 to e3
rook c8 to d8
rook h1 to g1
we'll see if that diagonal is going to
pay off rook f7
f8 f7 long castle
so one of the things i want to do is set
the world record and blindfold blitz
consecutive games playing 64 consecutive
blitz games um one after another
a7 a5 okay
uh let's try let's go for it actually
knight
c3 to e
2. i was going to go to e4
and then i saw some pro
8584 uh okay okay you gotta roll with it
uh knight e2 to d4
once again we gotta introduce the rule
to make it fair
if you only have 30 seconds left you
should be able to play yourself bishop
b4 to c5
let's try uh
king to c2 how much time do we have you
have 53 es53 as well
a takes b3 knight takes b3
bishop b4
rook to g5
rook c7 track king b1
rook f7 rook d1 to g1
bishop f8
bishop to d4
queen a6
uh quint to f1 24 seconds you want to
take over
uh let's play let's let's just we'll
just go with you right queen c6
queen g2
rook g1 g2 pre-move he's thinking huh
yeah queen is expect
bishop c3
queen d3 king b2
h6 rookie five
rook e8 uh rook to a5
knight c5 to remove queen d7 knight c5
on the board
bishop takes c5 applied rook takes c5
rook beatrice
king a1 sorry we're losing on turn queen
takes g7 he offered a draw i'll i'll
take it
what do we got here g7 did you hear that
could have done that but yeah like
probably would have lost some time
drama so tough to do because even
speeding up like normally one needs like
three seconds to say the move then say
it back and then to make it over the
board
good job good job 0.9 so we got